bonjour s'il existe une seule carte
postale avec château et en forêts il
existe une autre soleil plus intime et
plus secrètes c'est pierrot quand
écrivain photographe qui nous propose
cet autre regard
aussi nous partons dans le loir et cher
à y voi marron pour rencontrer ce
photographe à l'oeil atypique traverser
la sologne équivaut souvent à longer des
murs de forêt des forêts c'est raide
arbres chétifs posé sur un sous-sol
argileux et humide le paysage y semble
sans perspective fermer un homme
passionné à reprendre cette seule année
cherchent à la comprendre sans
concession pierrot quand nous livre sa
vision du pays où il a toujours vécu le
paysage de la sologne il a toujours été
totalement artificielle est voulue par
l'homme et ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui si une volonté humaine c'est
que ce paysage il est en train de
devenir un paysage de l'abandon du
laisser faire
pierre est photographe et écrivain il
vient de réaliser son sixième livre sur
la sologne
pour lui le paysage solognot ne demande
qu'à être travaillé pour mieux exister
j'attends avec impatience qu'on se mette
à défricher la sologne
j'ai envie qu'on coupe des arbres je me
fais un plaisir me fais des bois mais
pas tronçonneuse
parce que ça dégage du paysage va ce
sale renouvelle ça le remet à neuf sa
maison il l'a fait de ses mains mais
auparavant il a dû créer la clairière la
sologne pourtant n'a pas toujours été
synonyme de forêt ont tourné dans une
ancienne landes fait et c'était un
parcours à moutons à perte de vue
et depuis la myxomatose depuis les
lapins ne broute plus les nouvelles
pousses et bien la lande
elle se base
et
le moutonnement convoi tout au fond
c'est les sépultures
elle date de l'âge de faire c'est-à-dire
800 ans à peu près avant jésus-christ
vers qui a déjà trois mille ans que des
gens se sont installés ici ça correspond
à l'époque des premiers peuplements de
la sologne donc cette zone et est
défriché il ya 3000 ans et j'ai tout
lieu de penser que depuis 3000 ans elle
est cultivée au fil des siècles la salle
home subi de profondes modifications le
moyen-âge voit apparaître la
pisciculture plus rentable que
l'agriculture des étangs sont creusées
4000 seront en fonctionnement au xvième
siècle avec ses élevages de poissons et
de bétail la salle on connaît alors une
relative prospérité la sologne est
entièrement habité cultiver avec les
seigneurs de la cour de france avec une
forme de prospérité et d' équilibre et
voilà ce que me raconte cette épine noir
à la renaissance la bourgeoisie et la
noblesse montre un intérêt pour la
sologne bien placé entre paris tours et
bourges
beaucoup y bâtir ont châteaux et belles
demeures ces populations à porter elle
elle possédait le sol les domaines
il ya très peu d'époque où les paysans
sont sur le neo son propriétaire donc
peut-être aussi que ces gens ils ont
aussi contribué à modeler l'image parce
que selon qu'ils ont une orientation
bien agricole ou qu'ils en font un
domaine de chasse ou aussi aujourd'hui
on peut penser qu'un territoire ça peut
faire un golf
on n'a pas le même paysage dès la fin du
19e siècle les territoires de chasse
organisée s'agrandissent la réputation
cynégétique de la sologne attire
agriculture et sylviculture relégué au
second plan c'est de leur territoire la
seule voix c'était redevenir friche et
ses forêts laissé à l'abandon
s'il ya des marécages aujourd'hui c'est
que cette sphère elle est abandonnée
c'est qu'on est sûrs plus les fossés et
qu'on ne fait plus cool et l'autre
et quand il ya plus d'hommes eh bien on
obtient ça c'est pas le paysage le plus
valorisant mais c'est le plus
identitaire parce que la sologne a été
faite d'une succession d'intérêt et
d'abandon donc on l'oubli quelquefois
pendant des siècles
et puis elle ressurgit alors moi ce que
j'attends c'est qu'on s'y intéresse à
nouveau
j'attends une chose c'est qu'on se
remette à la défricher qu'on se remette
à la cultiver
parce que la sologne c'est un réservoir
de terre toute neuve l'hérault quand
rêve d'une seule langue vivante
diversifié tourisme sylviculture
agriculture et pourquoi pas chasse sa
sologne pourrait être celle-là - confiné
- confisqués au bout du compte
son souhait serait que les solognots
décide du paysage dans lesquelles ils
veulent